Final Fantasy 15 releases worldwide
September 30 but your chance to win
prizes all summer long starts now
introducing the Final Fantasy 15
carbuncle surprise your chance to win
prizes like Final Fantasy 15 Play Arts
Kai action figures custom consoles and
even a car to get started pre-order any
version of Final Fantasy 15 exclusively
from the square Enix online store and
come back everybody to see what
carbuncle has for you the earlier you
preorder the more chances you get to win
epic prizes all summer long like action
figures ruin Final Fantasy accessories
wireless stereo speakers limited custom
Xbox one consoles a fully loaded
entertainment center the exclusive
Sindhi mobile DLC where you can show
your appreciation for the hammerheads
finest mechanic even if you don't take
home the week's featured prize every
time you check in with carbuncle you
have a chance to earn square Enix member
reward points redeemable in the online
store as well as an entry into the grand
prize sweepstakes where you can win a
luxury car
better one carbuncle has something for
you the Final Fantasy 15 carbuncle
surprise pre-order on the square enix
online store good luck